I don't think anyone would object to the
the nature of which we left Afghanistan
it was a mess we left 85 billion dollars
worth of hardware and you know now you
hear Iran and whoever's getting their
hands on it uh so no doubt that we could
have left a lot cleaner no doubt but the
concept of just leaving Afghanistan or
fundamentally leaving Afghanistan I
think a lot of Americans were just so
sick of the fact that we're still 20
years later how the [ __ ] are we still in
Afghanistan yeah right so can you
appreciate at least not the manner in
which we left but the fact that we at
least got out of there you do you agree
that there was at least a major appetite
in America to get out of Afghanistan
yeah I mean if you go back to my first
video I said I'm not saying we have to
be in Afghanistan forever but I am
saying that I went on to what I was
saying I I personally believe that we
should have left a small footprint in
Bagram that's my position do I
understand why the American people were
over Afghanistan yes I think it's
short-sighted because you know just look
at the the al-Qaeda coming right back
into Afghanistan like you need some type
of base and presence in my opinion it's
a hotbed there's probably three or four
countries where you know terrorism grows
and Afghanistan is one of them bottom
line and so I think just from a national
security standpoint we need to have a
footprint we already owned that terrain
it made a lot of sense for me but
um do I acknowledge that the American
people were over Afghanistan yeah
absolutely and what what we when we
pulled out would we have 2 000 soldiers
in Afghanistan we started with 2500 on
one April and then we went down to 650.
okay so it was in minimal force and we
we were keeping peace in order that's
right that's right so that that exactly
right with 2500 troops we owned
Afghanistan we owned Afghanistan so the
investment was 2500 troops and you own
Afghanistan but that was too much right
and so that's I you know and you just
look I wish somebody had the stat for
how many forces are in Europe right now
there's not a lot of terrorism being
created in Europe I mean there is some
but not to the point of Afghanistan and
we probably have you know 50 to 100 000
troops in Europe right now right so it's
just you know do the math it seemed like
a good return on investment for me Stu
this is a pretty blunt question but um
you know there's a phrase that I think
you've used this Pat that in the Taliban
they said that well you guys have all
the watches but we have all the time
like
spend the next couple decades here buddy
spend 50 years here 100 years we're not
going anywhere okay but at the same time
you're talking about United States
Military Marine Corps
number one
in the world versus a bunch of sandal
footed you know machete wielding gun
toting dudes how the hell did we not
just those are AKs okay how did we not
beat the [ __ ] out of them and just move
on like well how why was it even close
so I think we won most tactical
engagements now that doesn't that's not
all of them obviously but you also got
to keep in mind technology is one thing
but uh the the most lethal weapon is a
human mind and so if I grew up in
Afghanistan wearing a man dress and
sandals but all I was told I didn't have
any TV all I was told about was the
Warriors that fought the Russians and I
was taught how to use an AK and I had my
buddies and that was like the only thing
in my world I don't care how much
technology you got I'm gonna bring some
lethal Force to bear and the people that
we had in our American propped up
government in Afghanistan were not the
real men the real men were the ones that
were you know grew up hearing stories
about fighting the Russians and they got
with their buddies and they got little
gangs together and fell within the
structure of the Taliban went over to
Pakistan got some more training and then
came over and fought and so you know I
don't the Taliban was never a terrorist
and that's I I talk about that in my
book they were the government they were
the conventional Force we displaced them
it was confusing because we were
fighting a global war on terrorism in
Afghanistan but that only strictly
applied to Al Qaeda which we cleaned up
very quickly so then we found ourselves
in a position where we were going
against the conventional Force the
Taliban and like you said how you
started this was they had time on their
side they were willing to wait us out
and so anyone that's willing to wait us
out if the American people get to a
point where like we don't want to be
there anymore then they're going to win
like you can't exterminate them right
you can keep winning tactical battles
but then it requires the American people
to say we're going to leave 2500 in
Bagram Air Base so we can continue to
pound them with air support when when
required
yeah you're you're really emphatic that
2500 troops in Bagram Air Forces and air
bases all we really needed I I think so
yeah I mean
you know crazier things have happened
but again we've been doing that for the
last five years so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]